durante la campaña o el salario denunció
en muchas ocasiones supuestas
irregularidades en el sistema de Voto
electrónico asegurando que podría haber
fraude pero previo a los comicios dijo
que iba a reconocer los resultados
Entonces cómo se interpreta este
silencio
es difícil interpretar
institucionalmente una persona que nunca
respetó la institución de ser presidente
de la república así que
por sonar está perdido y está aislado
esto los sus principales apoyadores se
han reconocido la victoria de Lula y
esto le hace aún más aislado
políticamente de lo que ya se estaba
esperando y lo que ya se estaba
proyectando Bueno y qué sigue si el
presidente bolsonaro decide impugnar los
resultados
no hay condiciones de impugnarles
resultados en verdad
la urna de electrónica brasileña tiene
una cierta seguridad jurídica que no no
permite
cuestionamientos que van más allá de lo
que sea las totalizaciones la
verificación del total de cada una de
las sesiones Así que las posibilidades
jurídicas de evolucionar están muy
cerradas y por más que intente
cuestionar los resultados no le va a
salir porque ya le falta apoyo efectivo
para cuestionarlo Bueno pero si el
mandatario decide no reconocer a Lula
qué se puede esperar de sus seguidores
podría haber un estallido de violencia
en el país
y ya tenemos brotes de violencia en
verdad la propia falta de de conexión
del bolsonaro con su gente está
limpiando la gente también a tomar
actitudes por su cinismo tuvimos salido
de violencia en Paraná principalmente
interior de bahía por lo que yo tengo
noticias y algunos lugares en relación
en especial a la base de Los camioneros
de Los camioneros que están camioneros
que están ahí trabajando con transporte
no los transportistas es una clase que
que normalmente se reconoce como gente
de la clase de trabajadora pero que de
hecho se alinea a líderes populistas que
se que defiende intereses conservadores
y nada bueno de verdad que por más que
haya violencia las propias fuerzas
armadas ya reconocieron que
aceptarían los resultados y que se
respetarían los resultados y las fuerzas
policiales deben seguir Así que no
seguir las fuerzas armadas así que no se
espera mucho más de lo que bolsonaro
puede hacer por más
instala que sea su postura y relación a
los resultados